ea sports hockey league sports gaming's
greatest online team play experience is
more competitive and customizable than
ever in NHL 17 the first step on your
road to glory is to create and customize
your player including new head and
facial options here styles and equipment
once you lock down your look it's time
to step onto the ice where you can take
part in our new drop in system lobbies
now roll over from game to game giving
you the best chance to build chemistry
with other like-minded players with the
deepest customisation we've ever
featured the possibilities are almost
endless as you tailor every aspect of
your team's identity you begin with a
blank jersey template and minimal team
branding options as your team progresses
you'll unlock new customization items
including custom logos alternate
uniforms shoulder patches and much more
looking good is one thing but having
home-ice advantage takes your team to
the next level start off in your local
community rink but like any player you
always have to think bigger as your
brand grows and your team progresses
slowly your stadium until you've grown
into a full size state-of-the-art arena
NHL 17s all new arena crater lets you
customize everything including your
buildings architecture seating patterns
gold horns and songs and much more
having the ultimate home for your new
franchise will make that sellout crowd
seem bigger
ever heard in the past getting into the
game for new player classes open up new
styles of play for your team with 18
classes to choose from in total you'll
now have more options to fine-tune your
optimal strategy on the ice as games are
completed and milestones are hit you
learn player badges and level increases
unlocking customization items for your
player team and arena taking yourself
and your team to the highest level is
never easy but in our most competitive
and customizable EA sports hockey league
yet we're making sure the journey there
is just as fun is that dealing at the
top